[Music]
Who decided that the main street is straight? It's
a hassle to go back and forth between the shops you want to go to.
It's
not just bad, it's better to leave it as much as possible. It's
round and it
doesn't enrich the back
alleys.
There's an older sister
[Music]
It's okay to
die eran
I'll go without time
[Music]
Follow it 5 Good invention
Here
[Music]
If you get angry, you won't notice why you're spinning around the same place  I'm sure
Ebifurya wasn't interested in anything other than robbing, so I'm sure he didn't look at the town properly
.
Well, it's nice to go around the same road forever
It was a good idea because the city belongs to us.
[Music]